thank you everyone and welcome to the
Academy's 2019
nickel fellowships in screen writings
Awards okay thank you somebody's excited
nickel fellowships have been awarded by
the Academy since 1986 to identify and
to encourage talented new screenwriters
and to nurture and include diverse
artists and storytellers who are
critical to keeping our industry vital
and relevant in addition to handing out
awards since 2013 this event has
included a live reading of scenes from
each of the award-winning screenplays
performed by a cast of remarkable actors
this is one of my favorite nights at the
academy I've been an eager audience
member for all seven live reads inviting
a whole group of my friends to join me
each year my posse is out there
somewhere tonight but everyone here is
in for a real treat this event is the
culmination of a year-long process this
year it began with get ready seven
thousand three hundred and two scripts
submitted by writers in 70 countries all
50 states and even a member of the
military stationed outside the country
all seven thousand three hundred and two
scripts were read in multiple times by
teams of professional readers and this
year that included three graduates from
the Academy's new diverse reader
training workshop which offers free
training in screenplay analysis to
readers in underrepresented communities
who will hopefully increase our chances
of connecting with unique new
storytellers readers select 1000 scripts
in the first round 365 in the
quarterfinals and 149 in the semi-finals
Academy member volunteers read the last
149 multiple times to select 12
finalists until that point readers have
no information about the writers all the
scripts are red blind it's kind of like
the voice but without those chairs that
swivel around
the committee then reads each of the 12
finalists scripts multiple times to
decide on the nickel fellows for the
year and the five new nickel fellows are
please hold your applause until the end
Aaron Chung for princess Vietnam Sean
Malcolm for mother Karen McDermott for
lullabies of La Jolla Walter McKnight
for street rat alley punches her ticket
and Rene Palais for boy with a kite
congratulations to you all
[Applause]
before I before I join you in the
audience I would just like to thank John
why senior manager of the nickel
fellowships program and her team chris
carr qi and melissa park for beautifully
shepherding each stage of the nickel
program thanks also to Randy Hebert camp
managing director of preservation and
foundation programs for his dedication
to the nickel project and to all the
academy gold talent development and
inclusion initiatives Thank You Randy
I'd also like to give a special shout
out to our CEO the Academy's Don Hudson
who's in the audience tonight we thank
her for enthusiastic support and her
focus on diversity and inclusion in in
all aspects of the Academy and I want to
thank the more than 200 Academy members
who volunteered to read 149 scripts in
the semi-final round and of course
special thanks to the nickel committee
23 devoted Academy members and governors
who volunteered their time and worked
tirelessly to assure that this
fellowship upholds its standards and
discovers the best and the brightest
each and every year and now it gives me
great pleasure to introduce the chair of
the nickel committee please welcome
acclaimed director and academy governor
Jennifer yuh Nelson
thank you David
and thank you to John Y and the Academy
staff for making this night possible
they work incredibly hard so if you see
them give them a pat on the back
welcome to the nickel fellowship in
screenwriting Awards and live read it's
gonna be a great night where we get to
celebrate the bright new futures and
careers of a select and talented group
of writers let's take a peek at the
moment this year's writers got the news
[Music]
hi this is members of the nickel
committee and we would like to tell you
that you are a 2019 nickel fellow oh my
god Wow we loved your script next year
it's gonna be really exciting thank you
so much
I am absolutely honored and I'm blown
away
I was shocked even to be a finalist
citizens just crazy congratulations
Hollywood so much
[Music]
so wait so I'm a fellow right you you
are nickel fellow yes
of the thousands of scripts submitted
only 12 become finalists and even though
five will become nickel fellows this
year being a finalist is in itself an
amazing achievement so I'd like to ask
the finalists here tonight to please
stand for a round of applause
[Applause]
tonight marks the beginning of a year of
fellowship one where the winners right
over the writers whose work you see on
stage tonight will receive support
mentorship and most importantly access
access so their words and ideas can
reach audiences and screens everywhere
this year alone past Nikhil fellows have
worked on the following projects escape
room relive extremely wicked shockingly
evil and vile the kid Dumbo
Brian banks just mercy unbelievable Mary
for all mankind and that's just this
year a nickel fellowship can kick open a
door and offered that chance for a
talented writer to show what they can do
in fact our director for the read
tonight
Geeta Malick is a past nickel fellow I
remember her winning script dinner with
friends a fun and insightful story about
an American in Indian American family
and everyone thought it was just ready
to go out and make so that's what she
did
[Applause]
this spring she wrote and directed her
feature film now called India sweets and
spices and it's finishing up in post she
is also running a pilot for Tristar
based on a young adult novel and she was
the first recipient of the Academy Gold
fellowship for women at 2018 has become
an inspiration for others to follow
she'll be directing an amazing cast of
actors thank you to Tyrese Gibson Rosa
Salazar Amandla Stenberg and West Duty
for showing their support to the Nikhil
fellows tonight let's celebrate our
winners and their work in al-qaeda
Malick will begin a read thank you
thanks Jenn and thank you to the whole
nickel team and to the Academy staff for
making this special evening possible as
Jen said it wasn't so long ago that I
was in one of those very seats as a
nickel winner myself sitting there in
awe as these magical actors actually
spoke the words that I'd written it was
an incredible experience and I'm very
honored to be here tonight behind the
podium one more friendly reminder to
please make sure your cell phones are
off
there is no photography or video
recording tonight there's just one
exception the Academy's social media
person is here in front somewhere
covering our event rest assured there
she is angel rest assured she will
capture everything and post to Instagram
for all of us and she's the only one
allowed to be using her phone so please
don't join her tonight would not be
possible without these four amazing and
talented people joining us it is my
pleasure to introduce the actors who
will be performing scenes from the Nikol
winning scripts a manless Stenberg is an
actress and singer-songwriter she
portrayed ruin The Hunger Games
Madeline Whittier in everything
everything and star Carter in the hate
you give she will next be seen in Oscar
winner Damien Chazelle musical drama
series the Eddie for Netflix Amandla
Stenberg
[Applause]
Tyrese Gibson is a filmmaker six-time
Grammy nominated musician and
philanthropist Gibson just wrapped
production on the upcoming film Morbius
part of Sony's Marvel Universe alongside
Oscar winner Jared Leto he can be seen
that starring indie on Taylor's thriller
black and blue alongside Oscar nominee
Naomi Harris
Tyrese Gibson
[Applause]
Rosa Salazar is a film and television
actress currently starring an undone for
Amazon Prime previously she played the
title character in the film Elita battle
angel she has appeared in The Maze
Runner and amazed on her series and also
appeared in the Netflix films the
kindergarten teacher and bird box Rosa
Salazar
[Applause]
Wes Studi is an actor and film producer
studio serious Kerr 11 days ago at the
governor's Awards
[Applause]
he's appeared in many many films
including hostels avatar and the last of
the mohicans Wes Studi
[Applause]
[Laughter]
alright let's dive in our first scripts
is Princess Vietnam by Erin Cheung in
19th princess Vietnam in 1980 a lonely
Vietnamese girl with friends and falls
in love with an imaginative Irish girl
as they confront racial prejudice in
their small town after a fiery incident
fable and Aisling our two young lovers
are forced to split apart fabled
struggling with her disapproving mother
and Ashley going into hiding ever since
fable professed her love
Aisling is feeling doubt in their
relationship wanting some distance fable
awaits a phone call from Aisling a
connection after days of silence
interior Sue's house kitchen continuous
fable prepares dinner for herself
putting rice in a bowl and pouring
lukewarm soup in another interior room
continuous fable eats alone the phone
rings fable drops everything to answer
it hello intercut with interior
dilapidated apartment complex Lobby
night
Aisling is that one of the payphones she
takes to the corner were an abandoned
doll a raggedy cat with both eyes
missing lace crumpled hey princess
hi fable can barely contain her joy
how's the other side it's going and your
mom fable holds her breath she listens
intently for any signs of her mother
just in case she pulls the phone closer
to her lips and speaks in a hushed voice
she's fine that's good both girls are at
a loss for words
searching for the next thing to say
how's my cousin treating you oh he's
been cool with me so far
Wilma - I never really spoke to her
before she kind of reminds me of my mom
yeah she asked about you what'd you tell
her just that you need some space I
didn't mention them you know good girl
another tense silence I saw your dad
hazing
Aisling his face drops oh [ __ ] he came
to the theater
he misses you Ashley he tell you that no
but he just looks I don't know
sad he just looks really sad did he
mention all the Vietnamese he gunned
down - Ashley you don't know my dad do
you
Ashley stiffens her knuckles crack how
can you even say that you didn't see him
papal takes a moment she's considering
her own words what she's saying about
Bill she stands firm you didn't see him
I saw him plenty a beat babel takes a
breath I'm sorry Ashley I'm just telling
you what happened okay Aisling softens
swallowing her anger I'm sorry to fail
checks for her mother again
hey what can I ask you something shoot
did you really ask me to leave because
you needed space Ashley knows the answer
but she doesn't want to say it I do
fable why do I have the feeling it's
something else
Ashley takes a deep breath there's no
avoiding it she knew this was coming
people don't think it's you you did
nothing wrong
what are you saying I'm I'm getting to
it I it's too [ __ ] hard it's
something you said what did I say the
night before we left you said
these words and I don't know what I was
supposed to say back Fable tries to
recall that night it's flooding back to
her she shuts her eyes I said I love you
beat yeah fable pinches the phone hating
herself ready to bang her head against
the wall Ashley I'm so sorry I didn't I
was don't know it's like I said it's me
you did nothing wrong
no but I did I did god I'm so stupid I
don't think I I don't know if I fail
can't bring herself to lie can I just
take it back
Ashley bites down on her lip you can't I
mean you shouldn't
fables swallows her tears even on the
phone she's trying to regain her
composure firm strong no matter what
Aisling on the other hand rattles the
payphone
yeah okay then I guess that's that right
people I want to be with you I do but I
don't know if I can feel that same thing
yet fables eyes water yeah I get it I do
they do that word it's poison to me it's
okay usually really but it's not your
fault
I know married you Aisling forces are
left through her tears I must sound like
a broken [ __ ] record they fabled
Merce musters up a smile but it falls
quick your fable cut short because she
knows they've reached the end
stay safe Ashley Ashley wants to say
something else it's right on the tip of
her tongue but she knows better yeah you
too princess fable hangs up first
and intercut she stands by the phone her
dinners getting cold behind her the
whole house is a hollow shell she grips
her mouth tight she can't let her tears
escape she refuses just around the
corner on leans against the wall her
head pointed towards the dining room
table whether or not she's been there
the whole time
it's clear that her little girl is in
great pain let me introduce our two
presenters for this award both members
of the nickel committee Marcus who is
co-president of strand releasing which
is celebrating their 30th anniversary
this year with retrospectives across the
country he resides in both Los Angeles
and San Francisco and he served six
years on the nickel fellowships
committee and Kirsten Kiwi Smith is a
screenwriter and producer she co-wrote
the hit comedies Legally Blonde ten
Things I Hate About You she's the man
and the House Bunny among others this is
her sixth year on the nickel committee
presenting the award to Aaron Chung our
marcus who and kiwi smith
thank you thank you guys
oh that was beautiful that was so
beautiful we love this right now we when
we read this script we sat together and
like teenage girls yeah and we were like
pairing notes we said oh my god we just
absolutely love this one yeah we flipped
out we flipped out like we fell
headfirst into this world and heart
first and these characters are so
beautiful and you know the relationship
is complex and the writing is so poetic
Aaron it's just gorgeous you know Aaron
just brilliantly captures the
naturalness and authenticity of teenage
female voices and what's crazy is he
graduated from film school two years ago
and and he has written five screenplays
this is his fifth screenplay
he's written across so many genres he's
written action horror sci-fi he's
written a high school comedy which I
personally cannot wait to read and he's
culminated his work culminated in this
screenplay and we got to meet him for
yesterday which feels like a lifetime
ago I want him at the luncheon and he
reminded me that we'd actually met
before because he was an intern a year
ago from my manager so we've already we
were longtime friends cut to now a year
later and he entered his very first
screenwriting competition the nickel
anyone which is so impressive
and and yesterday we got to hand him his
we got to hold his hand him an Oscar to
hold and we just feet for like the first
time and we just have a feeling this is
not gonna be his last time that wasn't
his last time that was only his first
time holding an Oscar and we Aaron just
congratulations we we thank you for
bringing all your your poetry and
artistry to this stage and and to the
community we just can't wait to get to
work with you and and get to know you
and congratulations and make thank you
for making such a great script about two
girls who fall in love yes such a
beautiful way yes
[Laughter]
please come on up Aaron
[Applause]
oh my god there's so many of you um well
first of all Thank You Kiwi and Marcus
for that very very flattering
introduction thank you to Wes Rosa
Mandela and Geeta for rescuing my words
Wow
thank you to the Academy Jennifer Joan
the entire committee for this
opportunity and for seeing something in
me that I haven't seen yet
um and thank you to my Florida State
family my close friends my colleagues my
mentors and teachers who have helped me
and guided me to develop my voice and to
make this script and most of all thank
you to my family my tireless mother my
resilient father and my supportive
sister and my amazing brother-in-law
thank you so so much for just everything
so before today as I was preparing the
speech I was writing about Who I am and
why I chose to become a writer and why I
chose to write this script and it
recently just felt off to me because
that's not the reason why I want to
write I mean I want to share my voice
but it's not just my voice it's
everyone's voice and I want to connect
everyone's problems and struggles and
conflicts and show that we have a lot
more in common than we believe and I
wrote fable on Aisling two characters
these two kids who had every right to
not be together because they were so
different and I and they just happened
to find each other and fall in love and
through that they've brought a little
bit of hope in their crumbling world and
I know that sounds a little cheesy and
belongs in a Hallmark card but I believe
it brings a little true because
not just storytellers but like all of us
people we have this amazing superpower
to empathize and connect and understand
each other in ways that no other living
creatures can but we often don't use
that power and instead we weaponize our
experiences and our opinions and our
intellect and our accomplishments to
make others feel inferior and silence
them which is just a shame because we
all we are all sharing this common goal
this one dream which is to try and be
better versions of ourselves than we
were yesterday
so I stand before you today to make a
promise that tomorrow or the day after
that and the day after that I will try
and try to be a better person than you
see here today I will try to empathize I
will try to listen I'll try to speak up
for others and give a voice to the
voiceless and extend a helping hand to
those who are in dire need of it and I
promise that I will try to be just a
better role model and I feel like a lot
of us we all should have that goal and
although we will all stumble and fall
and make mistakes trust me I have made
billions of them and I regret and feel
so ashamed for so many of them but no
matter what it's it's what we should do
because it could bring a little bit of
hope and love into our own crumbling
world so thank you so much you are all
wonderful lovely beautiful people thank
you
[Applause]
you're wonderful and lovely and
beautiful too Erin our next script is
titled mother written by Shawn Malcolm
it's about a Syrian mother trapped in
Aleppo who becomes a sniper to defend
her family in this scene Farida and her
son Sammy are trapped in their
rebel-held neighborhood in Aleppo
surrounded by regime forces on all sides
her husband and father have disappeared
after venturing out to find medicine and
the situation has never been more dire
when a charming rebel commander offers
her food in exchange for a home-cooked
meal
she has no choice but to obliged
interior Frida's apartment dining area
later that night the power is still out
the dining table is lit by two candles
and a flashlight
Farida sits with Sammy next to her the
soldier across from them they're
enjoying minced lamb with bread and
chickpeas all three eat with gusto Sammy
is shy not looking up much but enjoying
the food
my husband says not to eat near the
window when the power is out we've
established salat perimeter around the
area it's safe he chews heartily then
washes it down with water between the
snipers like myself and our anti-tank
missiles every time they try and enter
we stopped him she listens eating
modestly rarely looking up Sammy looks
up for a moment stares at him are they
going to blow up our house soldier
studies him for a long moment no the
regime can't afford to waste munitions
on empty buildings so they wait on the
outskirts avoiding losses they believe
if they can circle us and wait
we'll give up but we'll never surrender
Aleppo right
Sammy nods as if he understands looks
back to his plate soldier takes another
bite savoring it we have reinforcements
coming armed with more gifts from the
Americans if we can hold out there's
talk of a negotiation in Geneva maybe
even a ceasefire those words send a
glimmer of hope across the table she
looks at Sammy
notices him rubbing his eye excuse me my
son is very tired she rises picks up one
of the flashlights
I'm not tired mama she takes him by the
arm I know I know
say goodnight to mr. Hameed and thank
you for dinner thank you for dinner mr.
Hamid soldier smiles at him good night
little soldier she guides Sammy away by
the beam of the light interior Sammy's
room continuous she tucks him under his
blanket and hands him the flashlight
don't waste the battery okay okay will
you feed the kitty
yeah I'll feed kidding okay
I miss Bubba me too my love every time I
pray I ask Allah to bring him home me
too
okay Allah is watching over us remember
that good night good night mama
she turns off his flashlight leaves his
door slightly ajar interior Freitas
apartment dining area continuous Frieda
sits back at the table across from
soldier I can tell you're a caring
mother thank you
loving your child isn't hard it's
natural yes instinct she sips her water
then looks over at the sniper rifle
leaning against the wall I could never
do what you do he thinks for a moment no
one is born a killer we only fight
because we have to he stares at her
maybe we're not so different you know
you and I she looks at him not sure she
agrees but unwilling to challenge him I
don't know
rather it's instinct or destiny but I
know it's his will it seems to me our
instincts often go against his will but
how could I know for sure he shrugs
here's what I can tell you when it's
your life or theirs
the act is simple you raised the barrel
resting it on your arm listening or the
window sill just like this focus the
scope finding your target in the
crosshairs and you hold the butt tight
against your cheek to move with the
recoil exhale deeply so your breathing
doesn't move the barrel and when all
your breath has left your body and not
one ounce remains Wow
pull the trigger physics does the rest
she looks at him his eyes only seem
colder in the dim light he puts his arms
down something changes in you you know
it can never be undone when you accept
this it becomes easier she looks at him
suddenly aware of how uncomfortable
she's become with a stranger in her
house at this hour well I hope you
enjoyed the meal we appreciate your
kindness he leans back studying her it's
not a problem I can protect you and your
son she looks at him a bit sideways
we're fine thank you my husband and my
father
I didn't want you to say I'm sorry I
didn't want you to say it in front of
your son
but you realize you will never see them
again right she stares at him hard
gaze narrowing he's a survivor and he'll
be home anytime I know and he's very
resourceful he bores back into her with
his eyes you're lying to yourself we're
surrounded the regime would never let
him pass through
he's been disappeared he's been
disappeared if he's not already dead she
stands I want you to leave now
please he looks at her a dark glint in
his eyes he reaches into his pocket
pulls out a nine-millimeter pistol and
casually rests it on the table keeping
it tight in his hand don't make this
difficult you knew I wanted more than a
meal and you let me in no one has to
know
he stands the gun in his hand moves
closer she's shaking a pious woman like
you but could be stoned to death a pious
woman like you could be stoned to death
do the right thing for your son keep
your mouth shut he rushes forward
smothering her with one hand as he puts
the gun to her head with the other
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Stephen you lucky is a documentary
filmmaker Stephen you lucky is a
documentary filmmaker a former HBO
studio executive a feature producer and
most recently Dean of the school of film
and television at Loyola Marymount
University for eight years
last year he stepped down from LMU and
weeks later was accepted into the
Academy and joined the Nikhil
fellowships committee he is currently
working on a documentary on progressive
Evangelic olds presenting the award to
Sean Malcolm is Stephen you lucky
[Laughter]
I'd like to say that when I first
started out when I fell in love with
film I made documentaries and then when
I started doing feature as a fiction
work I still always found that films
that had a documentary basis or that
could have been could have been
documentaries were the ones that most
most interested me I look for example
the Battle of Algiers a film that could
take the reality of documentary yes
applaud the reality the documentary
doesn't yet at the same time what you
can't get in a documentary a fictional
film can supply when I read mother I was
absolutely overwhelmed by the fact that
I thought I was seeing something that
could become as good a film as the
Battle of Algiers it is an absolutely
timeless work you've got a sense of some
of the drama in that terrific scene that
you just you just saw and I just wanted
to I'm very very proud to be able to
present the writer of that script Sean
Malcolm the nickel fellowship award
because I hope and really pray and think
that there's a good chance that that
film that script could be made into a
film because it actually is the timing
is perfect absolutely perfect and for
whoever is interested in the film I know
some people are interested in it already
I would just urge that that hope that
that happened and on that note I'd like
to have asked Sean Malcom to step up
you
Wow Steve and I had no idea that you
were gonna equate me with something like
that and your words are so kind thank
you so much it's very hard to see all of
you out there but I know you're there I
have a few words I'll try to do it
quickly because I know we're on a time
limit but the truth is I do have a few
things to say so thank you for that
introduction thank you these actors that
was absolutely incredible you guys are
amazing for sharing your talent and time
tonight and breathing words breathing my
words our words into life for the very
first time when you write something you
don't have the benefit of anything other
than hear it in your head and you guys
are absolutely stunning thank you Geeta
for directing these scenes it's
incredible obviously I have to thank the
entire Nicol team Joan and Randy and
Chris and Melissa wherever you guys are
out there you're absolutely amazing this
week has been phenomenal
and of course all the readers and the
Academy judges who give their time every
year and their energy to this incredible
fellowship we could not do this without
you and you guys are so generous also I
just want to say a shout out to the
nickel alumni who spent their time with
us this week they shared their wisdom
with us and that was incredibly
incredibly helpful of course lastly but
not least in terms of my initial thanks
we have to thank Don and Guillen ickle
for the creation of this fellowship this
Fellowship has been such an inspiration
to me and so many writers around the
world for so many years it's an
incredible gift and obviously an
incredible legacy so thank you to them
also I just want to quickly say thank
you to the Academy because I've always
really really wanted to say that
wherever the Academy is and thank you
specifically to the committee all the
members of the committee you guys this
this honor that you've bestowed on me
and the other four fellows this year is
it's really beyond comprehension I'm
absolutely humbled and also the other
finalists that were in our group it's an
incredible group of writers and I'm
absolutely stunned by all the talent and
just privileged to be part of this words
are never really gonna fully capture
what this means to me
but I am a writer so I figured I would
try imagine you've been slaving away at
this maddening pursuit called
screenwriting for 20 plus years and
you've really gotten comfortable with
the idea of obscurity it's fine really
total obscurity it's very comfortable
I'm good with it and then suddenly one
day you find yourself in the Academy's
headquarters on the seventh floor of
this very building you've just had lunch
with Eva Marie Saint in a room full of
legends and icons your phone is buzzing
because the producer is trying to get a
hold of you somebody who wants to make
your script you step out into the lounge
to return the phone call you're looking
at the panoramic view of the Hollywood
Hills and you find yourself staring
right at the Hollywood sign it's
literally it's ridiculous right it's
it's it's so on the nose nobody would
ever buy it the only thing that came
into my mind was a talking head song
once in a lifetime and you may say to
yourself well how did I get here
literally and then it was oh my god what
have I done that's the magic of the
nickel that's what this is
so how did I get here very quickly we
all take a different path Aaron's path
so straight and narrow mine so
circuitous if that's the way you
pronounce it circuitous thank you so the
truth is my journey began twenty-one
years ago in 1998 and in 1998 I actually
submitted my very first screenplay and
ironically as evidence I have my very
first letter right here and actually I
was looking at this today I mailed this
script to 8949 Wilshire Boulevard which
is the building we are standing in for
I'm standing in you're sitting on 21
years ago and yes for the kids out there
we did mail them in there was not a
thing called PDF so if you can imagine
thousands of physical scripts coming to
this building and how they did it is
just unbelievable shortly after that
letter was sent in I got my first deer
Shawn unfortunately your screenplay did
not advance to the quarterfinals and so
began a very long and twisted romance
from 98 to 2019 year after year I kept
writing submitting I tried dramas I
wrote a black comedy I wrote some
science fiction I did a ghost story I
did a techno thriller what do these guys
want from me I even wrote a screenplay
about a screenwriter who writes a
screenplay about a screenwriter and one
of them dies along the way I forget
which one it was
it wasn't being John Malkovich trust me
mostly it went like this dear Shawn each
year the competition gets harder we
regret to inform you that your script la
blah blah blah blah but here's the thing
every single time I felt like giving up
a little piece of positive reinforcement
validation would come my way from the
nickel
congratulations you made the quarter
with this script congratulations
this one has advanced they would pull me
back
and then came mother and this story
unlike so many others it started with a
single photograph it was a picture of a
young boy in Aleppo about the same age
as my son who's here tonight
he had just survived an airstrike just
minutes before and I knew I had to
somehow tell a story I didn't know who
he was and I probably never will but for
the first time in my life I tried
writing from my heart instead of my head
and that made a huge difference it's a
lesson as a writer that I will never
forget I know this is a celebration
tonight but it would not be right for me
to stand here and not say a word about
the Syrian people it's simply this we do
not have to accept what is happening to
our fellow human beings on this planet
we do not
every one of us can make a difference
together especially when we act together
if you want to help but you're unsure
how a great place to start is to simply
go to white helmet org or rescue org
they are doing work on the ground and
you with a few bucks can make a
difference let me just wrap up quickly
by thanking the people who've made a
difference in my life my mom Patty is
here tonight mom I love you I have no
doubt that my loyalty and love and
respect for all the women in my life
began with you I want to thank all my
friends and family that are here tonight
and around the world there's too many of
you it's a tree with many branches but
your love and support has meant
everything to me and I appreciate it so
much I especially want to thank my
beautiful wife Ivana she's here tonight
as well everyone knows I won the lottery
when I met you among so many other
things that I love about you your
instincts are flawless and so even
though we have a different taste in film
I know that if I write something I like
and you actually like it too I might
have actually done something different
very decent my two kids are here tonight
Julianna and Aiden guys you're my pride
and joy I love you with all my heart and
being your dad is the best gift I will
ever have and lastly I just have to
thank my dad Robert furo he was many
things in his life he was also an
English professor and an absolute
connoisseur of the written word and for
a self-taught writer like myself who
never made it to college having him as a
dad turned out to be a bit of incredible
good fortune even though we were so far
apart thousands of miles apart for many
years he read all my scripts he gave me
his feedback and he never once had a
harsh word or said anything about my
stories he only ever incur
while there turned out to be the last
script that he would ever read he told
me he loved it and he was convinced that
something good was bound to come of it
and tonight proves he was right as he
usually was and so I just want to accept
this fellowship in his spirit because I
know it's his love of language that is
embedded in my DNA it is his love of
story that runs in my blood and it is
his kindness as both a father and a
teacher that is forever written in my
heart thank you
I just need some water
all right our next script is called
lullabies of lauhala by Karen McDermott
separated from her family during a
desperate border crossing and held in a
cage for migrant children 14 year old
Dahlia Ramirez draw strength from the
wisdom of the poetry of a Spanish
revolutionary as she struggles to
survive in the aftermath of a brawl in
the cage Dahlia spends a hellish night
singing lullabies to the younger girls
trying to drown out the screams of boys
being beaten by guards and then finally
a moment of peace in this scene she
meets a 16 year old Salvadoran boy named
Juan Alberto who will become her first
love exterior recreation field day
watching the smaller boys play soccer
Dahlia hears the sound of dusty
footfalls behind her and a voice see it
out there the warning Dalia turns to see
one Alberto follows the direction of his
gaze I'll pass the fence blue and orange
with the face at Lua painting on it the
Aztec god of water
tell your squints into the distance
looks for a colorfully painted rock -
tack prayed to prevent drownings I see
it I'm wanna bet it though he gives her
a charmingly
don't laugh I smile you're the one who
brings Hector over at night I am Dalia I
know yeah she smiles looks back out at
the distance what's the warning Rock
warning about wellness is flushed to the
ground so you can't see it unless you're
right upon it the gringos don't know is
there they don't know how to read the
warning how do you know about it there's
a hole in the fence you tried to escape
no no no there's no place to escape to
I just wanted to see the rock close up
they stand in silence both looking at
the bit of colour of their culture in a
sand and barbed wire filled horizon
do you know Miguel Hernandez the poet
one alberto shakes his head he has a
poem about a well it gives me hope she
recites in Spanish when Alvin Algeria
Piedra tres Piedras Moreau
troz Moreau a Mason wanted stone after
stone one well after another one Alberto
listens his dark eyes drawn into the
story or its teller as she continues
granita trabajaba Gonzaga this time Juan
Alberto provides the translation he
laughed he worked you saying
Dalia smiles una Alba Neil Korea pero
aquellos rila Brava
sukar sell again he translates
Jason wanted but that man was fashioning
his Jail en sobre fueron precipitous el
y el viento and both he and the wind
were thrown and taste worker he
considers he dies and the well he built
but you said I gives you hope the
American president is always building
stone after stone she looks out at the
stale desert but the wind is coming for
our next presenting duo we have Peter
Samuelson who is a producer and the
founder of five charities for children
who are seriously ill homeless or in
foster care his 26 films include
Arlington Road wild Tom and viv and
Revenge of the Nerds Peter has been a
member of the nickel committee for two
decades and Eva Marie Saint is an Oscar
winner four on the waterfront and
unforgettable in North by Northwest Eva
Marie Saint is also an Emmy winner and
for the kids among us was a voice of
Katara in the animated series The Legend
of Korra she has served on the Academy
nickel fellowships committee for 30
years presenting the award to Caren
McDermott our Peter Samuelson and Eva
Marie Saint
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's a nice high okay I thought it was
a shadow it's it's I love the idea with
the actors enact a scene from a from one
of these stories it just it brings it to
life and you're all wonderful I just
have to say that actor to actor Karen
Nick Dom McDermott who wrote lullabies
of la haula she said quote I felt
compelled to tell this story because I'm
outraged that children are being caged
in America
as a former attorney specializing in
child abuse and neglect I know what the
trauma experienced by neglected children
looks like she wrote lullabies of La
Jolla this is a story of a fifteen year
old and her name is Dahlia she her
mother and brother made the darkness
journeys to the border her brother was
killed she is put in a cage and
separated from her mother she is a brave
young girl and makes friends with the
other children in the cage
she loves books and she reads them
she becomes their mother but she misses
her own mother one day a well-to-do
white couple visits the cage and mates
Dahlia they signed the papers and drive
her to her beautiful home by the sea she
goes to school and she tries very hard
to accept the situation however she does
miss her mother and she is determined to
find her eventually she does and her mom
working in a florists shop
Karen McDermott who wrote lullabies of
lauhala said I felt compelled to tell
this story because I'm outraged that
children are being caged in America as a
former attorney specializing in child
abuse and neglect I know that the trauma
experienced by detective and abducted
children looks like and I would like to
invite her to come up right now oh no
you're coming up the man's coming up
it's no secret to anyone here that we
are living in dark and dangerous times
what perhaps we should be focusing on is
the role that audio visual storytelling
is playing in the gathering darkness
those who through demagoguery seek to
divide us to emphasize the sense of
other to make us hate each other they
understand through training in reality
television that schadenfreude is a
potent base human instinct meaning
enjoying the suffering of others
reveling indifference enjoying someone's
misfortune and their downfall
luckily audio-visual storytelling can be
used equally well and perhaps much
better we hope for the forces of the
angels to prevail because the bully
pulpit that we are facing every time you
turn on news television has an antidote
and I'd like to suggest that all of us
here the professionals here whether your
creativity your art your science is
through acting or writing or directing
or producing or the myriad other ways
that we help to get films made we should
all be asking ourselves in this time of
peril and gathering darkness what we can
personally do beyond the next 7th sequel
to some franchise which is based in
using visual special effects to defy the
laws of physics we should be asking
ourselves what can I do to make my world
a little less grim how can i generate
empathy through the power of my pen my
voice my camera how can I lift people up
and emphasize the commonality of mankind
which links us all what Karen McDermott
has done elegantly powerfully with
emotion with with technique with with
huge impact in lullabies of la haula is
to show us that this family that is
thrown into chaos from the moment that
they have to escape from evil that has
killed the son in the family through the
new evil that awaits them on the other
side of the tunnel into the United
States which separates mother from
daughter and engages the
fifteen-year-old what we understand is
that family is family that these people
who speak a different language who look
a little bit different perhaps they are
us and we are them and Karen by telling
this extraordinary story of personal
bravery of a 15 year old who actually
realizes that there is something the
matter with being fostered by a
well-meaning but tone-deaf white couple
in their very elegant and expensive home
and had being thrown a lavish Kenzi an
era where the only Hispanic people
present are herself and the mariachi
band there is something wrong with that
picture and her being possessed to find
her mother which she finally manages to
do lifts us all up and shows us that
even in the face of evil done by people
in uniforms carrying guns and locking
children in cages using our tax dollars
even given that even though you know
Santa Jana said those who forget the
mistakes of history are doomed to repeat
them my thoughts go to 1932 1933 1934
somewhere else and the power of media in
that time Leni Riefenstahl and so forth
we need to every person here in the
Samuel Goldwyn theater needs to be
asking themselves as well as making a
living as well as getting my material
made as well as getting that next acting
assignment how can I actually use
whatever god-given skills I have to lift
up my world to emphasize what we all
have in common and to build bridges
rather than walls I have the great honor
with Eva Marie Saint to ask Karen
McDonald to come up and receive her
nickel fellowship in screenwriting
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I didn't realize the power of that last
line until I heard you recite it thank
you so much
Tyrese Gibson I never thought of when
Alberto as sexy apparently he is he just
made more work for me Tyrese I have to
go in and add some scenes where he's
shirtless now thank you so much Peter
Samuelsson and Eva Marie saying this is
such a dream come true
thank you for putting so much thoughts
and generosity into that introduction I
have to say this whole Eva Marie Saint
thing is it's throwing me it would throw
you to thank you to the nickel committee
Joan why all of the nickel judges but
more than anyone tonight I need to thank
my students the people who inspired this
script first year composition students
at California State University Los
Angeles
cast in LA in the house
that surprises me because a couple of my
students asked me if they would get
extra credit for coming tonight I said
no but you'll get public recognition in
the academy award theater and they were
like but no extra credit in the fall of
2018 I knew I wanted to write about the
caging of migrant children in America I
was infuriated and I wanted to put a
face to the policy a family separation I
wanted us to see it through the eyes of
a child but I knew it was a difficult
subject to think about let alone write
about so I talked to my mexican-american
students about it and they said we'll
help you and they did my students helped
me with the Spanish they fact-checked me
they did they told me stories about
their families border crossings and
about the conditions in their home
countries and all of this informed the
scripts two of my students allowed me to
use their names Thank You Juan Alberto
for the use of your beautiful name I'm
sorry I had to kill you
[Laughter]
Thank You Stephanie for the use of your
beautiful name I'm sorry I had to kill
you too hey I had to kill some children
I was trying to make a point and I was
trying to make Eva Marie Saint cry I
don't I wasn't I wasn't trying but if
she was going to cry the cry I had in
mind was the one from the auction scene
and North by Northwest it was a
beautiful cry she just welled up so
beautifully thank you Michael for never
letting me give up no matter how hard I
try to Michael's favorite thing to say
to me is you got the goods I don't even
know what the goods are but thank you to
all my friends and family who support my
writing in an earlier version of the
script I named them all and then listed
all the reasons why I was thanking them
you would have hated it
it was 12 minutes long I have one last
thank you to the meryl streep funded
writers lab for female screenwriters
over 40
thank you for mentoring and empowering
mature women writers I attended the lab
two years ago
and I think we have some alumni here
tonight in the audience I want to end by
saying that I agree with Peter Samuelson
these are dark dark times but the wind
is coming I think thank you good night
[Applause]
[Laughter]
our next script is boy with kite written
by a Renee pal a boy with kite is about
a surly loner who inherits an odd little
boy and must overcome her loathing of
him to uncover the truth about the one
person they both loved in this scene
ten-year-old Ben makes an unwelcome
entrance into 50-something Stella's life
interrupting her time with her Silver
Fox boyfriend Linney she lets the boy
stay but doesn't have to like it
interior farmhouse Ben's bedroom dang
despite the bed and closet it's pretty
obvious this is storage the shelving
units are filled with bags sacks and
cans but the room looks clean and the
bed linen fresh Stella opens windows
turns down the bed checks under it for
some reason muttering the whole time oh
well clear dumb shelves out later I made
it ready best I could they didn't
exactly give me a whole lot of time just
said you'd be coming and here you are
Ben puts his backs down he looks around
the room and lands on Stella she just
stares back nothing left to stay then
you got a P bathrooms next door he nods
okay
we're done here and leaves interior
farmhouse kitchen de Linney nurses a
beer when Stella shows up she's put on a
shirt and jeans and head straight to
making coffee
so the boys family
go on I'm listening I don't know what
for you're the only one talking well you
be that way hey you got nothing but time
she throws a look at the bottle in his
hand you're gonna make that last till
next Sunday aren't you I can make it
last till the end of days I'm that good
but Stella keeps her mouth shut
despite that threat so you have a
brother what was his name again Gabe so
you got a brother named Gabe it's like
Chinese water torture head I had a
brother he died a month ago that shuts
up Lenny like nothing else Stella
well hell so so you just lost him I
don't know about that doesn't seem like
you can just lose someone if you haven't
seen him in ten years but his boys here
well that's because you're looking at
the winner of the little orphan lottery
turns out I'm the only bloody has he's
not worm food and that all kinds of
[ __ ] up bad as [ __ ] up as us being
together for seven years and this being
the first I heard you're having a
brother Lenny don't I'm not you are
putting his hands up Lenny surrenders
okay okay so I'm gonna go I'll let you
get your stuff settled I'm plenty
settled good it'll give you more time to
get the boys settled in then her
flesh-eating glare slides right off him
what's his name anyway damned if I know
this throws lynnie foot for a full
second but it's Stella so we just kisses
her in heads Oh Oh get his name try
starting with that huh interior
farmhouse third floor hallway Knight
fence door cracks open to reveal him in
PJ bottoms and a t-shirt several sizes
too big he heads down the stairs
interior farmhouse Stella's study night
he opens the door to a room filled with
bookcases tables chairs and desks all
overflowing with books there's a TV set
from the 80s hooked up to a VCR both
belong in the Smithsonian but apparently
they work as evidenced by what's playing
gaze glued to the TV Ben doesn't see the
precarious stack until he bumps it it
sets off an avalanche of books and stir
Stella from her place in front of the TV
she uses the remote to turn the screen
black what and the holy hell are you
doing here Ben rears back face pale eyes
huge wait sit go on sit
she's not just a chair forward with her
foot he hesitates but finally takes an
uneasy seat why are you up a shrug he
doesn't know that's when Stella realizes
I figured you were just quiet but this
ain't that is it what's wrong with you
can't you speak no response
just those watchful eyes so why are you
up
can't get to sleeping got a worm in your
head Ben touches his head looks alarmed
at the thought got a real worm Jesus
Christ
I meant a feeling like how I knew you
were gonna be a boy when your father
told me he knocked up your mother she
looks at him really looks and what she
sees does not make her happy
god damn you're everything I knew would
happen he was just too blind or too
stupid to see it well too bad for him
too bad for me too I suppose there's a
bitter taste to her words so she grabs a
random book off of a table shoves it at
him here it'll help you sleep go on get
your ass back to bed
Stella hits play on the remote and the
TV sounds follow Ben out the door
interior farmhouse Ben's bedroom day Ben
climbs into bed with the book on Paul
Klee master of the abstract he flips the
pages and reaches a painting the CAC and
demonic anguish and dark it's Cleese
nightmares transformed into art Ben
shuts the book and then pulls the covers
over his head sequence stars the inside
of his blanket becomes a galaxy of stars
within the sweeping strokes of van
gogh's starry night he reaches up to
pluck out the brightest among them he
holds it tight and closes his eyes
[Applause]
Tiger Williams is a film and TV writer
adjunct professor at the USC School of
Cinematic Arts the UCLA School of
Theatre film television and a creative
advisor with the Sundance Institute
screenwriters lab his credits include
menace to society the perfect guy and
the upcoming Netflix series madam CJ
Walker he is currently a writer on the
FX series snowfall presenting the award
Ternay pillai is Tiger Williams
[Laughter]
this light is not for my height I loved
where's Rene I love the script the
picking
the bickering the bantering the fussing
the fighting the little boy who's not
talking you know you you read it and you
get into it Nick where am I headed what
is this and I have to say yes you made
me cry
Rene healthful Malaysia and which was
notified that she won the nickel because
she applied for a first passport and no
but she also needed a US visa but the
earliest interview they could get was on
November 8th but with the help of our
amazing nickel staff meeting was
arranged with the Cultural Affairs
office at the US Embassy in Malaysia and
they agreed to craft an appeal to the
Consul General and it was the expedite
the thing and Rene's friends got
together and pulled some money and she
hopped in the car and drove two hours to
kuala lumpur to the embassy and we're
happy to have her here
[Applause]
you know at first glance you know boy
with kite it's a it's a simple story
about a woman and a man and a you know
and a boy that uh pins this this family
and ultimately illuminates their lives
but it's it's much more than a simple
story it's complex it's as complexes as
life is it's a very human and universal
story and it's not about it's not about
a woman it's not about it's not about
Malaysia it's not about the things that
often as particular genders or people of
color are expected to write it it
touches all of us we know all of these
characters we are all of these
characters I came away from the script
caring deeply about these characters and
their lives and as I said she brought a
tear to my eye and in a time when movies
are increasingly becoming technological
marvels not marvel technological marvels
I believe the ability to infuse real
emotion into our work is a skill that's
more valuable than ever and I value you
Vinay and I couldn't be more honored to
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Wow
Thank You mr. Williams I I had no idea
what was the Salazar if you were like 40
50 years older but you're not it was
amazing hearing all it's amazing just
being here because you've heard the
story of my journey and on that front I
have to I have a whole bunch of
thank-yous I'm so sorry to subject all
of you to this but I'll make it very
fast thank you to Sangha Pillai Irvan
hail
Julian Lee Jenny Christy Lau Zoe Elena
Molina Kasturi cassavan as Lina muhammad
yousuf some of them gave me money when
times were bad all of them gave me food
and shelter when times were really bad
and they never once told me stop writing
but I I wouldn't blame them if they did
fact is I've never taken a writing class
I come from 14,000 miles away I don't
even speak English half the time
and I want to write movies here in
Hollywood what kind of fool thinks that
is possible
but more importantly the reason for this
is because when you come from the place
where your writings not understood not
encouraged when there's no room for the
stories you have to tell when you're not
given the space to exist then even
though these are dark times here it's
dark times all over the world and uh
Hollywood starts to look well Hollywood
starts to make sense and that's a bit
scary isn't it and the sense that it
makes is that there are freedoms here
freedoms that so many of us take for
granted
for example the freedom to write about
exotic places like Nebraska
the freedom to write about people who
are nothing like you but who are you the
freedom to connect with others
irrespective of whoever whatever
wherever you are because like Ben that
little boy who doesn't speak can speak I
suspect all of us like me I wanted to be
heard I think we all want to be heard
and that's why all this work all of this
by Joan and and Chris and the whole
Nicholl fellowship team it's work that's
not only important it's necessary
because if not voices like Stella and
Lenny and Ben and mine would never be
heard because if it wasn't for them the
Academy and the nickel committee none of
people like me we wouldn't get a chance
to be heard and I realize now after
meeting the nickel committee yesterday
it's because every single one of these
people I always want to say this well
frankly my dear they do give a damn they
do they totally do
so now what I get from all this is
moving forward when ever I'm I'm gonna
be told that I'm all wrong when I'm not
given the room to exist or the freedom
to be then I'll remember that
improbabilities well they can happen I
am one of them they can be so many more
thank you
[Applause]
our fifth script is street rat alley
punches her ticket written by Walker
McKnight when the leader of a gang of
homeless girls makes a deal with an
underworld boss to earn a ticket out of
her dome sealed city she and her street
urchin family become targets of every
criminal in the place human and
otherwise in this scene Ally the leader
of the Street rats and Moon Pie the next
oldest member thank you returned from
the streets to their sewer room hideout
with a hard-fought and stolen meal there
they join the rest of the gang and enjoy
a meal and a moment's respite from the
cruel city above interior the rat's nest
day Ally and Moon Pines Ally and Moon
Pies scramble down the ladder into the
rat's nest an old sewer access room 15
by 15 wood crate in the center their
table candles provide light a maze of
pipes covers the ceiling for tiny wood
plank beds hang from the walls each full
of old blankets a stream of sludge water
flows lazily through the center out of
one big drainage pipe and into another
alley reaches the floor looks push pop /
confused where's Rob what happened to
your hair
push pop has a kind of greased up
fauxhawk she Pat's it it's like a shark
fan go up it did guppy 11 crawls in from
one pipe bright-eyed and eager
she's air dynamic now did you bring
anything to eat all four girls huddle
around their box table push pop and
guppy look hopeful Ally fakes a sad face
sorry cup just didn't make it happen
today
guppy tries to hide her heartbreak it's
okay we ate Tuesday Ally slams the dog
on the table guppy shrieks what is it
the best meal you ever ate find me a hot
pipe the girls blur into motion climbing
the walls using the backs of their hands
to test pipes number 6 is boiling Ali
carries the gaga produces a knife and
slices it up on top of the pipe it's
sizzles guppy holds her stomach like
she's been punched smells like fish
liar you ain't never had fish I had fish
once too many feathers later the four
girls hunched around their crate each
with a piece of warped tin as a plate
homemade knives and forks sawed off
plastic soda bottles as cups each filled
with water
Ali dishes out the cooked GOG it looks
like grilled white fish guppy is in awe
wipes at a tear there's so much Ali
lifts our cup the rest raise theirs to
the Street rats to the rats to street
rat Ali she did this the girls dig in
it's life it's heaven
it's everything this is my favorite food
you always say that you said it last
week when we found that potato potato
was my favorite food last week now it's
GOG do you think we'll eat tomorrow Ali
will try listen the guppy wanting to eat
every day think she's a queen of the
bubble do not I just like eating guppy
lets out a huge burp the girls burst out
laughing this is their joy later the
rats clean up their tiny sewer home
getting dark almost no daylight through
the grate they'd light more candles
guppy climbs into her wall bed one of
the lower ones Ali uses trickling water
from an unscrewed pipe to wash the
plates Moonpie leans in almost
whispering copy wants you to talk her to
sleep tonight she wants you Ali Ali
leaves her work and sits by Guppies bed
a hanging sheet in the candle inside
gives him an almost private space guppy
has an ancient beat-up earth globe in
her hands got your earth huh guppy turns
it around traces cities with her finger
what city did the bubble used to be in
nobody really knows but you have to
guess
Ali points to Miami
my a me why just like the sound of it
Jimmer swore it was New York but she
didn't know either what about you
guppy turns the globe to France and
points at Paris Paris if this was Paris
we'd be speaking Parisian silly but
maybe this is what Parisian sounds like
Ali looks confused then impressed are
there really other cities out there like
the bubble ones the train goes to oh
yeah they say if you get on the train
you can go to cities where humans are
still in charge no way humans in charge
just like it used to be before the bots
took over and people you did all the
science and turn themselves into odd
bodies Wow and you're going there one
day it's what we do
street rats all move on to the big world
eventually like jammer and wrecking girl
and gogo red before her but you're not
going soon right Ali's expression
darkens came there nobody inside the
bubble has ticket cept the big bosses
and they ain't giving him up jammer said
she'd send me a ticket but that was a
long time ago probably forgot I don't
blame her
she was way better than me a legend
alley fish is an ancient stuffed rabbit
out of Guppies blankets and puts it in
Guppies arms it's not weird or anything
me still having a bunny not even a
little
hey Ali blows out the candle hey Ali
I think you're a legend that's sweet but
you can't be a legend till you're gone
she draws the curtain
[Applause]
we have another pair of committee
members for our final presentation julia
chasman is a veteran film producer with
a dozen feature credits who's been a
studio executive at Showtime Universal
and industry entertainment currently she
runs her own home design company which
designs and renovates home in the Los
Angeles area she has served on the
nickel Executive Committee for the last
six years and has been a judge since her
acceptance to the Academy in 2007
Daniel Petrie jr. is an Academy Award
nominee for his screenplay Beverly Hills
Cop he is a past president of the
Writers Guild of America West and
current president of the Writers Guild
foundation he is also a former governor
of the Academy and a longtime member of
the Academy's nickel fellowships
committee presenting the award to Walker
McKnight R Julia chasman and Daniel
Petrie Junior
[Laughter]
street rat alley as you gather from that
beautifully performed scene leads a
small band of teenage girls in their
makeshift existence in the wildly
original ramshackle hellish city of the
future where they struggle to survive as
the eldest of the girls alley is charged
with finding food shelter and keeping up
the hopes of her younger charges with no
means of support and only their rickety
skateboards to make their way these
latter day heirs to the pickpockets of
Oliver Twist must fend off daily attacks
by boys BOTS and sadistic multi limbed
futuristic creatures as they scramble
for food alley not only keeps them fed
she keeps up their spirits and serves as
a mother to the orphan girls although
she's not much older than they are okay
the bombed out city where they live was
once one of the great ones was it Paris
New York San Francisco we have to wait
until the last train pulls out at the
very end of the story to find out Walker
McKnight has created a uniquely
terrifying and fabulous post-apocalyptic
city of the future as he put it himself
in his artists statement a fun dystopia
populated by multi limbed freakish
creatures and robots but the main
characters are all beautifully realized
young women and the spirit of the script
is undeniable full of action drama humor
heart and humanism it's a unique
combination for the sci-fi genre a
native of Atlanta Georgia
Walker McKnight didn't start writing
seriously until he was thirty the time
has been well spent though as the
assurance of his years shows in his
command of his craft and a voice which
is all his own please help me welcome to
the stage 2019 nickel fellow Walker
McKnight
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is a major phobia of mine and I'm
about to have a panic attack so I think
I'm gonna read this whole page in about
15 seconds so just hold on Thank You
Damon Julia for the incredibly kind
words
thanks to Gian Don nickel for the gift
of this competition and the academy for
putting so much effort in so many
resources into it for so many years
thanks to Joan Y and Chris Carr Chi and
the nickel staff for doing the hard work
of running the fellowship thanks to
Jennifer yuh Nelson and the nickel
committee for taking time out of their
wonderful careers to help those of us
trying to learn this craft it means a
lot and thanks to the other fellows and
finalists for being such fun and
supportive partners in this process I
also have to thank the great
screenwriting teachers I've had because
they've been huge my first teachers
Jenna Milly and Michael lucker my
professor jag Boozer from GSU and tim
alba who's been a big friend and
supporter these people have had to read
my worst scripts and it probably took
years off their lives to do so
I'm sure did but like great teachers
somehow they were still able to
encourage me to keep going and I think
if any one of them had said something
different than that I
I might not have thanked you two rows
and a mandolin and Wes and Tyreese for
that incredible read I never expected to
hear dialog that I've written spoken by
anyone other than the voices in my own
head and there are a lot of those you're
much better than those voices that was
incredible and thank you Geetha for for
directing that thanks for my brother
Brian for being a wonderful friend and
movie watching partner all my life but
above all above
all thanks to my parents wand and Walker
who fed my love of fantasy and sci-fi
from my earliest memories they're
reading to me and indulging my constant
requests to bring home VHS movie rentals
with monsters in them they have
continued to encourage their child in
this crazy career path long long after
he's passed an age that any child should
need to be encouraged in a career path
so I can't thank them enough and I love
you as Julia mentioned I really didn't
start writing until age 30 I have no
idea what I was doing before that just
staring at a wall I guess with a with a
relatively late start like that comes a
pretty healthy dose of imposter syndrome
I've often felt like I was trespassing
on somebody else's career field
something that was meant really for only
people who just knew it was their
calling since childhood or high school
or college or even their 20s and so for
15 years my imposter syndrome it's been
like a constant roommate and and lately
honestly it's really started to feel
more like the landlord really a really
terrible when banging on the door and
shouting at all hours
thanks to Nikol I now have something to
shout back and that's a really wonderful
thing to close I just want to say that
good stories are the most magical thing
in the world to me my favorite
storytellers throughout my life have
been able to conjure something out of
nothing and make me actually care and
the difficulty of accomplishing that
never ceases to blow my mind this is the
craft that I'm trying to learn and if
I'm ever able to bring even just a tiny
fraction of the thrill to somebody that
my favorite storytellers brought to me
then I'll be happy thank you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
well that concludes our 2019 nickel
award presentation and live read another
big thank you to our actors Amandla
Stenberg Rosa Salazar Tyrese Gibson and
Wes Studi
[Applause]
[Laughter]
congratulations again to the nickel
fellows as they begin their year thank
you all for showing them such a warm
support for anyone who's out there
writing or thinking about writing we
hope you feel inspired to put your words
down on the page and share your stories
safe journey home to everyone a warning
that the parking garages will close
thirty minutes from now so thank you and
good night
[Laughter]
you